faut-il remplacer le président de la
république en france par un roi et bien
oui nous avons osé faire ce duel la
monarchie est elle souhaitable pour la
france pour en débattre
à ma droite stéphane bern journalistes à
jour de france auteur de l'ouvragé
l'europe des rois aux éditions lieux
communs et face à lui jean michel
blanquer président de l'association pour
la déclaration du 26 août 89 vous nous
direz dans un instant ce que cela
signifie exactement alors stéphane bern
est ce bien raisonnable de dire en 1989
au moment où nous célébrons le
bicentenaire de la révolution
eh bien la france mériterait un roi je
crois que ce qui est important de dire
c'est que le système monarchique est
sans doute le système qui soit à la fois
qui à la fois le plus le plus
traditionnel le plus ancien également le
plus moderne
ce que je veux souligner à travers
l'europe des rois c'est qu'il ya douze
pays de la communauté européenne et six
d'entre eux sont des monarchies qui
vient en tout 10 monarchie dans le sur
le vieux continent et que ce sont les
premières démocraties du monde avant la
france avant les états unis en tout cas
pour les monarchies nordiques et d'autre
part il ya l'exemple du roi d'espagne
qui voici treize ans à restaurer la
monarchie et à instaurer un système
démocratique
alors je crois qu'il ya eu évidemment la
monarchie peut apparaître aujourd'hui
comme un système de gouvernement tout à
fait moderne tout à fait ancré dans la
réalité dans la modernité comme le
montrent les dix monarchies européennes
que j'ai voulu bros c'est un petit peu
non mais vous devez donc je parle au nom
de à des 89 qui est l'association des
jeunes qui préparent une nouvelle
déclaration pour le bicentenaire donc
tourné vers l'avenir l'avenir des droits
de l'homme ce que je pense sur cette
idée qui vient d'être défendu c'est que
au fond c'est une vieille idée qui
essaye de se présenter sous un jour
moderne comme on a vu que vous essayez
de le montrer en fait l'essentiel n'est
pas là l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est la
défense des droits de l'homme ce qu'on
voit c'est la véritable différence entre
les régimes c'est entre régimes
démocratiques et régimes dictatoriaux
finalement quand il ya une monarchie
dans les démocraties c'est un petit peu
pour le décorum un résidu de l'histoire
et aujourd'hui ce qui compte c'est en
fait de savoir qui a le pouvoir qu'il
ceux qui ont le pouvoir fort
heureusement ce sont les gens élus et
c'est eux qui défendent les droits de
l'homme donc je pense d'abord que c'est
une idée inutile pour cela et cela
ensuite une idée dangereuse parce que
c'est comme je disais c'est une vieille
idée qui se présente sous des
sous un jour moderne elle nous renvoie
quand même à ce qu était la monarchie et
c'est pourquoi on a fait la révolution à
savoir un régime quand même qu'ils
étaient fondées sur les inégalités sur
les privilèges
or je trouve que cette volonté toujours
de reparler de la monarchie comme si ce
n'était pas un débat fini correspond en
fait un peu à une montée des
rationalités aujourd'hui après tous
assimilable à ce que peut être le des
phénomènes de jeu comme le loto ou comme
d'autres phénomène irrationnel
on essaye de faire en fait du neuf avec
du vieux et on n'a jamais trouvé des
nouvelles solutions avec des feuilles de
l'ancienne solution
je crois que je crois qu'en fait vous
faites erreur à ce niveau là je crois
qu'effectivement il est intéressant de
commémorer le bicentenaire de la
révolution qui est une date de notre
histoire au même titre que 1700 que 1989
est le quatrième centenaire de
l'avènement d'henri iv et j'espère que
l'esprit de tolérance prônée par le bon
roi henri aura raison des commémorations
non ce que je veux ce que je veux avant
tout dire c'est que effectivement la
monarchie est une idée traditionnel mais
une idée moderne et vous parliez d'une
idée qui ressurgit une vieille idée et
vous fait je crois peu de cas de ce qui
se passe dans les monarchies européennes
dans ces 10 monarchie je crois que les
souverains atteignent des cotes de
popularité tout à fait extraordinaire
vous parlez de décorum ne font rien je
ne crois pas que ce soit un décorum
justement mon livre essaye de montrer
que lesdits monarque qui règne en europe
ont un pouvoir réel
écoutez le roi d'espagne est quand même
celui qui a instauré la démocratie en
espagne
le souverain belge est celui qui
maintiennent l'unité la cohésion de la
belgique qui serait une wallonie où une
flandre autrement la monarchie
britannique créé ce lien entre la
tradition et la modernité
les monarchies nordiques c'est son
symbole d'humanisation du pouvoir ces
pays partirait à la dérive s'il n'y
avait des amarres pour maintenir le
navire je crois tous ces points sont
assez importants vous parle nous
parlions de la france
c'est un point important il faut
absolument que la france vous raisonnez
en opposition entre monarchie république
moi pas du tout la date de 1789 et les
droits de l'homme ne mangeant pas plus
verte chez désolé monsieur blanc
air france en joker je ne raisonne pas
en opposition je vous dis que la
monarchie quelque chose de marginal si
demain on fait un sondage sur vous ou
moi auprès des français il tournera 99%
nos gens qu'ils nous trouveront très
sympathique c'est normal on ne fait rien
on n'est pas on n'est pas dans le débat
public on ne me prend pas position si ce
n'est aujourd'hui met donc les il est
normal que les rois soit populaire s ils
sont populaires dans des pays qu on les
conserve mais ne parlons pas de rétablir
la monarchie en france puisque vous dit
que ce serait pour rétablir l'unité en
fait fondée sur une sorte de tradition
qui existe c'est vrai d'ailleurs et que
cette unité elle existe justement autour
de la république les français sont
extrêmement divisée mais s'il ya une
chose sur laquelle ils sont venus c'est
sur le principe de la république
pourquoi les diviser à nouveau avec un
débat qui est vieux non je crois qu'ils
sont surtout sensibles sur le point de
la res publica la chose publique le bien
commun et finalement si je veux garantir
six 6 mois royal y je souhaite que la
démocratie soit véritablement garanties
comme le roi d'espagne nous en a montré
l'exemple
je crois que c'est parce que il faut
revenir aux traditions capétienne qui
sont les valeurs d'unité d'indépendance
de l'état et de continuité
je crois que les institutions de la vème
république voulu par le général de
gaulle sont pétris d'un esprit
profondément monarchique et je crois que
tout cela il faut vous le soulever faut
le souligner qu effectivement il y a le
rôle arbitral du chef de l'état il y a
le rhône la continuité à travers les
prises dans la république mais il manque
que je crois la légitimité la légitimité
historique la légitimité des services
rendus aux nations certes le président
de la république a la légitimité du
cercle du suffrage universel
mais quelle est cette légitimité c'est
celle de 50% des français contre 50% des
français fait la légitimité de
l'affrontement de ccc reprendre
finalement la france comme une sorte de
lutte fratricide une guerre civile dans
le but de s'approprier le pouvoir ou
mais finalement l'idéal de l'idéal de la
monarchie c'est au contraire la
réconciliation nationale oui mais enfin
encore désolé mais il ya une dynamique
l'unanimité des français sur le système
républicain qui compte ce n'est pas
qu'une unanimité sur monsieur mitterrand
monsieur chirac ce qui compte c'est une
unanimité sur les institutions or
aujourd'hui cette unanimité il existe
pour la république
les centres peut pas nier et elle existe
aussi sur un autre point qui est
fondamental c'est les droits de l'homme
et les droits de l'homme historiquement
je suis désolé en france ont été portées
par la république et aujourd'hui il faut
être cette fois je vais les prendre sans
sable je crois qu'il faut préciser sur
ce point peut-être un petit détail
certes louis saez a signé en 1789 la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen mais ce qui est ce qui est
important de souligner c'est que les
droits de l'homme ont été inventés
auparavant chemin que la culture
occidentale c'est le rêve est ridé des
droits de l'homme
cela dit je ne veux pas du tout
affronter je le répète monarchie
république
j'aimerais simplement que l'on ce que
l'on prenne conscience du fait que si
l'on veut garantir les institutions
voulue par les français des institutions
de la vème république il faut les
couronné il faut couronner son
institution par la présence à la tête de
l'état d'un chef d'état indépendant des
partis qui ne tienne sa position
d'aucune puissance financière d'aucune
puissance partisane un homme
profondément indépendant par vocation je
dirais même par naissance ou à écouter
fois que cet homme-là d'abord ne servir
à rien comme jeu comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure et que d'autre part en
france nous excusez moi mais les droits
de l'homme puisque c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit pour préserver la démocratie sont
extrêmement bien respectée grâce à des
institutions éminemment républicaine
comme le conseil constitutionnel comme
toutes les institutions qui ont un pas
encore nous vois faire et c'est là que
mon avis votre idée dangereuse parce que
si vous voulez vous dites la république
française en fait elle est là des traces
de monarchie vous avez peut-être raison
mais justement quand on le dit dano
normalement ça devrait être péjoratif
quand on le vit il ya de nouvelles
conquêtes affaires qui sont des
conquêtes républicaine mais conquête de
droits de l'homme il faut aller de
l'avant et cesser d'essayer de voir en
arrière de regarder en arrière
si certains pays européens marchent avec
des monarchies tant mieux pour eux
n'allons pas les enlever mais n'essayons
pas de changer ce qui est en france qui
marche bien qu'ils fonctionnent
démocratiquement et essayons au
contraire d'aller plus loin avec les
principes qui ont toujours inspiré la
république et des droits de l'homme
je sais quoi vous devez simplement un
élément de réponse si un jour en france
et est élu au suffrage universel une
personnalité contestable sur le plan des
droits de l'homme et de la démocratie il
n'y aurait aucun recours si la majorité
des français se prononcer sur son nom en
angleterre prenant l'exemple la reine
elizabeth parts à trois reprises dans
son dans l'histoire de son règne et qui
est long de 37 années a refusé de nommer
premier ministre
la personnalité qui émerge est selon le
système britannique parce qu'elle
estimait que ce n'était pas la
personnalité la plus apte à diriger les
affaires du pays cité d'une année je
pense qu'on peut reprendre les exemples
dans l'es10 monarchies européennes où le
roi est véritablement le symbole de
l'état le symbole le l'emblème le
drapeau est le garant le seul garant de
la démocratie et de des droits de
l'homme non je crois que vous avez une
personnalité alibi kirwan carlos qui est
effectivement une personnalité
sympathique et qui correspond à une
époque de transition de l'espagne
nécessaire et qui j'espère que j'espère
que l'espagne quand elle sera mue en
démocratiquement elle semble le devenir
pourra se passer de quelqu'un comme juan
carlos
mais je suis désolé un roi ne peut pas
faire qu'elle ne peut rien faire contre
une rame arrêt même si malheureusement
c'est un raz de marée anti démocratique
le roi d'italie était balayée par
mussolini n'a rien pu faire
24 février 1980 quand seul contre tous
contre l'armée notamment
mais le roi d'espagne alors il peut pas
à sauver la démocratie c'était
véritablement les remises à la rue dès
aujourd'hui mais quand on aura plus
besoin de lui on le bat les rats non je
crois que les espagnols aujourd'hui ont
compris que le seul garant de la
démocratie espagnole de la jeune
démocratie espagnole
mais beaucoup plus forte que vous ne le
croyez que le seul garant de cette
démocratie c'est le roi et finalement il
reporte et il continue dans cette
continuité que possède la monarchie de
reporter cette affection sur le prince
des asturies le futur roi d'espagne et
je crois que c'est là le fondement de la
monarchie et de l'intérêt de la
monarchie c'est que finalement vous avez
une famille une lignée de serviteurs du
pays et en france je crois que le comte
de paris incarnent aussi cette
légitimité
je crois qu'il défend comme comme je
vous le disais un peu en introduction
c'est dangereux de croire en des hommes
providentiels
c'est dangereux pour la rationalité de
la démocratie on a pu avoir des hommes
providentiels qui n'étaient pas des
hommes providentiels par le sang charles
de gaulle ans
1940 d'autres aussi éminent donc vouloir
que quelqu'un qui est né comme ça et
finalement normalement enfin selon mes
principes à moi est égal à tous les
autres et n'a pas a priori plus de
mérite que d'autres vouloir que cet
homme devienne providentiel comme sa
barre par l'état providentiel il est
l'héritier d'une tradition de service du
pays mais elles sont par exemple que la
révision des étudiants qui sont les
héritiers de dynasties qui ont créé
l'europe
je vous rappelle qu'on veut aujourd'hui
créer l'europe de 1993 l'europe existe
depuis charlemagne par des dynasties qui
l'ont façonnée mais l'europe a été unis
par des hommes de la république beaucoup
plus que par des rois qui se sent qu'il
a affrontés
messieurs je vous remercie d'avoir
échangé vos idées il ya eu un petit gag
que les téléspectateurs n'ont pas vu et
à la limite c'est tant mieux parce que
ça aurait peut-être perturbé un peu la
compréhension du débat qui était
intéressant c'est que vous avez utilisé
cinq fois votre sablier pratiquement à
chaque question alors c'est le feu du
direct a évidemment un petit peu
d'émotion je rappelle la règle du jeu
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent plus nombreux chaque jour
chaque débatteurs dispose d'un sablier
qui dure deux minutes et pendant ces
deux minutes s'il fait usage de son
sablier et une seule fois pendant
l'émission
l'adversaire doit le laisser parler même
s'ils disent que l'adversaire peut
considérer comme des énormités et mon
gros sablier ici n'a d'autre but que
d'expliquer à nos deux invités qu'il ne
leur reste plus que trois minutes parce
que souvent les invités au départ nous
ira c'est déjà fini mais j'ai oublié de
parler de tel et tel dossier alors
maintenant on visualise les trois
dernières minutes
et si vous n'utilisez pas tout votre
sablier vous pouvez c'est votre
c'est avec discrétion vous pouvez
laisser répondre votre adversaire ça
c'est vous qui décidez alors vous poser
trois questions
seriez vous favorable à une monarchie
constitutionnelle en france est une
question de monsieur berne qui est
royaliste
face à lui monsieur jean michel blanquer
vous pose la question suivante les
droits de l'homme sont ils essentiels à
l'unité européenne
et puis une question de l'a5 selon vous
la monarchie en 1989 c'est une
institution sympathique dépassé voire
scandaleuse donc ces trois possibilités
je donnerai les premières tendances de
vos votes tout à l'heure aux environs de
13h30
j'en profite également pour vous
signaler que si vous souhaitez
participer à un duel ou si vous
souhaitez que nous organisons
un duel entre telle et telle
personnalité sur tel sujet eh bien vous
ne l'écrivez l'a52 141 boulevard pereire
75017 paris
mais ne nous écrivait pas en disant
faites un duel sur le chômage il faut
lui dire faites un duel sur le chômage
en invitant monsieur x face à monsieur y
sur le thème est ce que la droite et la
gauche et la même chose je ne sais pas
c'est à vous de déterminer le thème du
duel donc pas de généralités comme ça
qui ne nous apporte rien mais des
propositions des propositions précises
messieurs merci dans quelques instants
nos traditions de 13 heures
[Musique]